i was telling um evan my co-host i saw
you though
years ago i saw you at um
the playboy manchester united oh yeah i
was there a lot you were [ __ ] good
i spent many days at the playboy magic
place
[Music]
oh man so this is an awesome episode of
um hot boxing
with um evan britton man and we got the
one and only evan
put it down on the table introducing
evan the one and only super bowl champ
fastest man in nfl history
willy gone what's up fastest man in the
nfl history willie well i don't know
about that i mean i'm sure at least
right i mean arguably but you know one
of them right oh yeah top top two or
three
oh so tell me that what what what speed
do you have to accomplish
establish that okay so this is it guys
there is
tv speed and then there's real speed and
natural football
a real speed okay so when you go talk
about real speed speed is measured by
the 100 meters in
any olympics so if you if you talk about
people who play the national football
league who ran great hundred meter times
you talk about bob hayes of course who
was a world record holder 995.
absolutely and you know the guy now
who's in the league who plays the kansas
city he's run nine nine he's good
cheetah
oh yeah yeah yeah he's ready he's good
uh when you talk about real speed you
got sam grady you got myself
you got ron brown you got uh james jeff
james
nehemiah was he was hurdles he was hurt
but he was fast but he wasn't
he was probably 10 flat tim one which is
amazing yeah what about the rocket
rocket was quick about his brother which
one
his brother oh yeah but rocket was
quicker yeah
but if you talk about top 10 i'm not
sure make rocket makes the top 10.
uh dale green makes the top 10. dale ran
10 i think 10
12 10 18. uh but when you talk about
real speed is different i mean
newscasters say oh my gosh he's fast
just because he caught someone who was
much slower
so it makes someone appears to be fast
but real speed is something that uh it's
gone
to me is two guys who claim to the best
in the world they're going exactly
and that's what it is that's that's what
you saying both because people say oh
you saying both people can beat you same
boat in football i go
you have no idea it's not even close
first of all in track
you go off a gun so your reaction time
is a little bit different in football
it's off your reaction time
so your time will be quicker so you're
actually gaining that laughter got to
beat you then but what's his name again
you're talking about uh justin gatlin
with the galaxy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you know it was is it
twilight years i mean it's like
when he was at his top when he ran nine
five nine no one was close i mean tyson
gabe was a close and he ran 9-6
so but usain bolt is a different because
he's so incredible speed
oh yeah yeah he's like unheard of human
beings well especially mike because he's
so tall
yeah he's six five six six right and
think about it a guy
six six is in front of a guy who's five
eight
yeah at 30 meters yeah that's not
supposed that's
not supposed to work that way but you
know he's an anatomy he's really
fast and he's a great talent and a great
guy happy guy you know
yeah he's enjoying his life for sure
he's a good guest on the pod
oh he'd be a great guy he's jamaican
yeah brother
that must have been incredible because
he had a lot of pressure on him back
then
of course but he was so confident the
guy died tyson was asking
the guy tyson mike tyson gay uh justin
gatlin
oh yeah absolutely and also his country
man um
what's his name south of powell yeah
southern power ran 972 and then you
johan blake johan blake was nine six
see those guys are in different strategy
there's nine six there's like four or
five guys six guys maybe
seven guys and then there's nine nine
nine eight and then there's ten in them
above so
tell me um what do you think um
how do you recover from that after the
race is over how do you how do your body
feel from this well see this is the
thing that people don't see all the hard
work i mean when you go out and box mike
people just see the results like oh
you're going
it's the same thing i mean you got three
months and four months of training and
doing that
right exactly absolutely same thing in
trying
to think about it you ain't looking
pretty in track we start in november we
start november 1st
to run in june so november december
january february mark we're
kicking butt we're on the beach we're at
the park we're running hills we're doing
weights we're pushing i mean everything
so what happens is when you run 100
meters you run
further in practice run 300 400 500 to
get ready to run at 100 so when you run
100
you can recover faster because you're
already you've already done it
so it's a lot of training i mean a lot
of training goes into that people don't
realize they just see the end result
yeah so as a real athlete you know we
all know we've been there
it's not what you see on sunday or what
you see on the saturday night when the
boxing it's all the stuff beautiful
monday through friday you know emma i'm
sure you haven't been football too we
haven't
bought those guys that could get in the
gym and could beat everybody
and
a guy one right now who is he he says
he's from
uh trinidad but we have no idea where
he's from
and he claims he's run 10-4 before 100
meters but
at practice i mean he just practices
never runs so
i think he's afraid to run really
because he he doesn't really want to
expose himself before it's really
i want him yeah i want to run against
the best yeah exactly i want to run
against the best
to push myself so hell yeah yeah
absolutely call practice guys
i'd be so pissed off especially being an
offensive lineman
and going against the dns every day and
like doodle throws some
nasty cass rush move absolutely right
beat the hell out of me and then we get
into the games i'm watching him he's
just getting ragdolled by this
guy on the other team all right exactly
yeah like that dude sucks
right the same thing i see in the fight
right whip my ass and get my phone with
this bum
knocking them down what though right
what are you doing i know
because the the nerve i mean i think
it's the nerve the pressure
of competing because competing is
different
absolutely from the great right when you
practice you're practicing when you but
when it's for real it's for real
you know and that's a different animal
we all know that because we've been
there so
it's interesting man in the competition
that's when all of that
training just happens oh yeah you're not
thinking in a game
you're not thinking the game you're just
it's reacting it's just overreacting
about carl lewis in his day
carl lewis okay i'll tell you my caller
carlos was great carlos and i actually
made the first junior olympic team
together and then we made that first
olympic team together we broke the
world's record together in a four by 100
meter relay
uh carl ran anchor i ran second and in
helsinki in 1983 it was the first time
any team ever had gone under 38 second
we ran 37
86. i ran second karl rand anchor emmett
king from alabama ran first calvin smith
ran third
and uh it was amazing helsinki but carl
carl was a guy
of course carl was the usain bolt of his
time
i mean he was undefeated in 100 200 long
jumpy
you know records and he was just an
amazing athlete really really amazing
athlete yeah
he worked out pretty good too oh yeah
carl carl worked out trained a lot
because he well he
loaned jump and he ran 102 so you had to
i mean in track and field
you you can't hide because it's you it's
a clock
if you don't do the work then the time
is not going to show so
carl had to work hard and i've been
around some amazing guy like walter
payton of course
in chicago walter payton is i met walter
before i was drafted by the bears
and so we become friends and so when i
got there to
have that friendship with him and see
the way he trained and the way he worked
it was amazing this guy was so strong
you ever trained with an animal oh yeah
he told me he told me yeah
it might mean you have to work out cause
i gotta get you back yeah yeah man mike
did he say that to you he was amazing
that's amazing dude walter was one of
the
the f he was he first of all it was a
practical joker he would do anything
you wouldn't know what was happening all
of a sudden a a ball of firecrackers
would go off at your feet or something
like that he was really crazy
oh yeah but he was so strong his his
forearm was like this wood here
so he hit someone like that he's always
in shape always in shape
remember that helios oh yeah
yeah we do we do heels up up sand too
which is oh my gosh it mike it kills you
you ever work oh you ever played against
lawrence taylor oh my oh my god
i got a great loss tell us
okay so so okay lawrence taylor now we
launched they won the super bowl the
year after we won it
so we were matched on the monday night
football game the first game of the year
of the two super bowl champions so i
played flanker so i was on the left side
and lawrence landed learning on the
the left side of his defense so the po
the coach called a play where i had to
go back and crack back on lawrence oh
so i was probably from here to the wall
to launch which is about 20 feet
so the first time he called i'd go in
lauren didn't see me i hit him here i'd
knock him down oh
oh my god he gets up cursing me out he's
like you little [ __ ] i'm gonna
kill you
and then and then he goes up to the
coach he goes over to the coach dick and
start cursing coach dick out
if you ever call that play get out i'll
i'll [ __ ] you up i remember
seeing you exactly and then so mike the
coach called the very same play the very
next time
okay so i line up again lawrence look at
me and go oh you gonna do the same thing
i go oh shoot i hope so as soon as the
ball snap i go
towards lawrence he turns around just
like that in my head i went oh
knocked me out i told you i was gonna
get you i told you a little money
dude i remember that oh yeah that was so
funny and lawrence and i talked about
that about three or four months ago we
laughed about it was really fun
um mike that's the worst thing
for the life and times of ltd oh god
right
he's this guy's not human he was he was
great you guys are very
similar man yeah oh yeah my you weren't
human either might believe me
yeah you were amazing mike i mean just
you you beat guys before they go in the
ring really
yeah because they were intimidating and
lawrence was like that i mean yeah deep
offensive trying to intimidate you kill
you oh yeah
dude lawrence taylor if you ever do that
again
dude i gotta do what i gotta do but you
know it was not pretty though
man the first time i don't know he's on
the field talking [ __ ] oh yeah
oh yeah i'll kill you oh yeah always
always
for sure it was crazy the first time i
got him though i knocked him down
that's one of the nastiest plays man oh
yeah nfl
those crack backs crack backs and you
got to hit him high you can't hit him
so i hit him i hit in this area which
was really hard but he didn't see it off
balance because he was looking this way
yeah
bam oh yeah man he got up mike he was i
almost ran i almost ran into the locker
room i was like man
we joke about it now i got to tell you
guys a story it's the
it's the worst bit of hazing that i've
ever
i ever experienced or saw it was second
hand
but when we were on the bears right it
was training camp
and we'd go to um in plattsville yeah
yeah exactly
um and one morning
our our rookie oh linemen kyle long he's
late
he's late and like we're all ready to go
out to practice padded up taped up you
know it takes a [ __ ] hour
to get ready for football prep right
we're all ready to go about to get on
the field and kyle comes pulling up
in the in a golf cart with some
assistant and he's like he looks
exhausted
we're like dude did you go out [ __ ]
partying all night
and he's like dude i had to sleep in my
car and we're like what the [ __ ] why did
you do that and he said
well last night when we went back to our
rooms i got in my bed and i'm just
sitting there looking at my playbook and
all of a sudden i see this movement on
my blanket
there was a tarantula in my bed
one of the vets had gone and put a
[ __ ] tarantula in the dude's bed
oh my gosh before he got back to his
room
i was because that's what they do that's
what they do that's
crazy i didn't sleep the next night
because i was like [ __ ] that
thing's probably running around
probably absolutely that's great oh
training camp stories are crazy do they
make you sing
rookie comes into the league they
usually make them sing the alma mater in
front of the the whole
team so they always mess with rookies
they make them pay for stuff they make
them do i mean everything was crazy i
mean that's the way it goes with rookies
yes funny i mean i have some stories
with the bears with crazy tell me about
mcmahon barry sanders oh my gosh barry
sanders
fake your teammates oh my god the guy of
course
you know what
on our defense while he was there the
offense was the
defense was there and barry was crazy he
was crazy his moves
because he's so low to the ground i mean
he make moves and guys go here and he's
over there it was just incredible yeah
i mean he if he didn't retire he'd
probably have 20 000 yards
yeah i mean he was amazing amazing
just a great guy and of course jim
mcmahon was a quarterback who was
really crazy man it's what still is i
can't say it was he still is crazy
jeremy's crazy i see him on the golf
course he was a man
he was he's crazy he was good though but
you know what jim was right for our team
at that time yeah he was perfect we had
dikka who was crazy yeah and mcmahon was
crazy so they both were like
butt heads but they were good for each
other what the guy you had was from
brown's the oldest
or the wilson oldest one oh this was
amazing
oh yeah oh yeah exactly yeah i still
stay in touch with all this all this was
great man
i mean we had three of the greatest
linebackers when you think about it yeah
mike singletary and wilbur marshall
those guys i mean i would take those
guys over anybody
those guys were amazing defensive in the
history of the league i think arguably
one of the best defenses in history
because they could do so much that 46
defense just put so much pressure on
guys
i mean those guys they worked hard we
train after practice even we have a hard
practice we stay after
another 20-30 minutes going through
drills and running and doing extra
things so
we really were dedicated to winning i
want to talk to you about
the bears because the chicago fans
they're some of the best
fans in the world oh yeah part number 85
bands are great
they're just and the funny thing is
about the bears is when i
came there they they had a good year i
think they made it to the playoffs but
they had just released air locker so
there was a lot of attention
yeah um but it's still like no matter
how the bears do
it's like last year was the 85 bears
right
and this year we're going back super
bowl yeah you know well until until that
happens again i think the 85 bears will
be revered because think about it guys
totally the city hadn't won a
championship in almost 60 years yeah
since 1960 or whatever so
the 85 bears came and chicago was always
known as the second city you know and
people thought oh well there's new york
there's
right oh there's dallas no chicago
somewhere but so
we sort of embody and bottle what
championships were made of and we
brought the interests of the entire
world
i mean we did the super bowl shuffle
which is the video
exactly yeah and uh i helped produce and
direct that and write that and
so we became like the folk hero around
the world
so people the interests of the nfl grew
i think by
30 to 40 percent that year and so we
also helped save football that year
because we
brought life back into the league maybe
you sort of refrigerated me a touchdown
oh yeah
no he didn't he's actually he almost but
he actually
yeah i think he had a stroke yeah he
lost he was down to like a hundred and
ninety two hundred pounds but now he's
back up at three hundred something so
but he has his challenges but think
about it fridge was
200 360 370 pounds we called him biscuit
because we said he was biscuit away from
400.
fridge fritz can stand
underneath fritz can stand underneath
the goal post and step and jump and dunk
the ball
free yeah yeah six point six two three
hundred three hundred and sixty pounds
freak out think about it that's close oh
yeah explosive
i mean it's thousands like this yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
he ran for a touchdown he uh tried to
throw [ __ ]
cool yeah exactly caught a touchdown but
no he was
he was good he was really good good
tackle we had a good team
let's talk about your stories with hugh
my star wars with you yeah with you
parties at the play boy normally
you know i've been placed where you know
guys and uh
strong figures in their country or
wherever that they can actually say hey
will you please go with mike
make them happy i said let's say this i
have fun at the playboy mansion i mean
i was there i started going when i was
in college i actually made the playboy
american team oh
sweet so i started going in college
before i got drafted in 83 so i was at
the playboy mansion from
79 to maybe a couple years ago so i've
seen everything at the playboy mansion
seen everything sort of done everything
so it was really it's a really amazing
place oh grotto is yeah the grotto was
great i left
the garage i was always high
i was always wide awake and understood
what was happening so it was good but it
was a great place i mean
it's it's a male's paradise really when
you think about it
and you know it it's it's a place where
i think
you sort of leave your egos at the door
and just go in from a fantasy standpoint
just enjoy it and and not
get caught up in the to who's not there
who's there whatever and just enjoy
yourself
by being there it was great but he was a
great he was a great guy wasn't he
um sounds cool i always
looked at it from this perspective he
didn't know me well he probably knew my
name but he didn't know me well but he
always showed me respect exactly
absolutely full family absolutely
brought food to me getting yeah food
you know take care of you yes awesome
guy
that's awesome thank you exactly the
parties i mean i like
i i went to like fourth of july parties
that were going movie night and
movies with them and you know some of
the other stuff like some of my dreams
yeah the movie night movies
the movie was not important it was just
everything around right he's like
exactly absolutely it's cool and it's at
the play bar matching beverly hills i
mean come on guys it's playboy that's
nice oh yeah ladies really nice
no it's an understatement oh yeah he has
beautiful ladies there they're all great
and they loved him you know because he
was
the american some of the american dream
you know he was he was awesome and he
treated him nicely i mean
they they got what they wanted he you
know helped them out and their careers
and
and just still they're rent i mean it's
all that stuff it's just part of that
that's what i did when i had all that
[ __ ] money i was helping girls
i know i know mike i heard about that
[ __ ] that
i don't blame you very generous very
charitable
oh man
so that's the beautiful part about mike
man right his heart
oh yeah no i know i know mike has a
harder goal i mean mike you don't
you might not remember this or know this
but i was in boxing for a little while
not yet i was i was a manager i met a
guy named layman brewster who you know i
knew layman
he married
from his first zero from zero to 11. i
was his manager yeah i trained him on
the beach every day we went to the gym
gold's gym and lifted
me to get
who just passed away a couple years ago
he came in and bought him out and just
you know he left and then
that was it so but yeah i love boxing
yeah boxing's pretty cool
mike i love boxing i'm a boxing official
i've watched every
every one of your fights thank you i
watched everyone if not if i saw some of
them live i
saw most of them on the tv and then i
saw videos but you know i just
uh when i first met you you might not
remember it was uh
in beverly hills yeah it was a charity
event and i came up to you and i say
mike hi willy god you go well i know who
you are
i'm a fan and we talked about that it
was cool so it was like really cool to
to finally meet you and to interact with
you which is great and and
that's respect and do some a lot of
activities stuff yeah absolutely yeah i
was doing a lot of acting and television
stuff i was on the tv series for a
couple years i was in the west wing a
couple of years and
so yeah now i'm shooting a deck of
documentary in my life so
and afterwards we're going to get you to
say a couple of things but i'm shooting
a documentary
and i'm doing it myself so we're taking
about two three years to really do it
right and uh it's gonna be interesting
so awesome dude
yeah i've done a lot in my life i mean i
made two olympic teams i made the summer
olympics and i win olympics
and you were on the team that boycotted
the olympics 1980 yeah 1998 tell us
about that
yeah i was like 10.
like 19. 1980 man i was 19 in 1980
wow yeah yeah man it was it was i was
carl lewis myself
ronaldo nehemiah edward moses
was amazing he's the coolest guy oh he's
cool he's so smooth he's like
a little new zen guy yeah yeah he's on a
smooth like
word mike he was undefeated for like a
hundred and twenty races
which is almost unheard of that's like
oh yeah and the 400 meter hurdles
which is a crazy technical event but
mike yeah he was a
only thing he was doing with weed right
but he was amazing so we all made that
team together man and went to you know
we had an alternate game which
has an asterisk i want to go miller in
that game which is actually but we had
actually more
people more countries participate than
the actual olympic games in moscow in
80.
we boycotted because the russians were
in afghanistan so president carter
thought we shouldn't go
which we all thought we should go and
beat them in their own field exactly
but the bad thing about is that the sum
the winner olympic team in 1980 went to
the olympics yeah this summer
we did yeah the hockey guys they won but
so they they didn't let us go which was
really
sad but we all were cocky we were 19. oh
it doesn't matter we'll go again in the
next one but it doesn't happen like that
mike you know i mean you
you get one shot in life sometimes you
don't give me the chances
that's what i was telling young kids now
the advantage of your moment exactly
this won't last for long it won't last
forever you're right take advantage of
your moment you have to go somewhere
else and be ready for your next
journey yeah yeah you have to prepare
for the next journey it's about
opportunity
to understand in boxing i'm a very lucky
guy and i you know i'm grateful
for god or the creator whoever i never
put i never planned
i never had a plan b with the get out of
here right i never thought about getting
right
yeah i was enjoying it don't understand
i thought this would last forever going
to say man [ __ ] you i'm tyson i'm a
[ __ ] guard it's going to last forever
you're crazy all right this and that and
this and that
and then you say [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
that's right when it's going it's
[ __ ] going everything else is [ __ ]
right like um osmosis what happened to
that this and that it's just all gold
right yeah no [ __ ] goals it's a time
clock
you're gonna have some extra [ __ ]
lawsuits on you that's what i have some
[ __ ] tax [ __ ] you gotta deal with
it
[ __ ] up yeah oh no
willie that remind me
it's a life though it's part of life man
it's what makes us who we are you know
it's one of those things that you know
it's a ride you know
there's a roller coaster you know you've
got ups and you've got downs and it's
just you got to ride it and when you're
going down you got to ride
when you're going you know what i
realized that um life is about giving it
your hardest
as long as you live exactly keep
fighting hard harder for what you want
in life
in life and just keep fighting hard and
hard and don't give up right you know
what i mean
yeah that's so true absolutely don't
give up
exactly a lot of my friends they gave up
died of broken hearts yeah himself
actually physically killed
himself for loneliness actually yeah
thinks it's all over because they don't
have no [ __ ] money
right they think it's over these are
great people but they're thinking that
right they don't have no [ __ ] exact
money because the society
thinks that you know that's a
measurement society's wealth is here you
got to be a certain blade but you don't
it's all in here it's all in here you
know it's all in the heart you know what
a lot of us don't
understand it took me a while that we
love you we we glad that you made money
with the champion
right but we loved you because
they loved you anyway right yeah and
what i'm trying to tell people michael
is that
every morning and every night i look in
the mirror i brush my teeth whatever but
i want to be able to
like that person that's deep you like
that person you see that everything
that's the [ __ ]
oh yeah absolutely so you like that guy
because of things that you've done
and the things that you're doing and the
thing that you know and think so if you
do that then it's all
everything's going great but now we're
kind of liking that guy locking that guy
in the mirror yeah
because you are a very special
individual a human being no one's like
you
no one's like me no one's like you we're
all special in our own way so
we have to understand and give what we
can it's all about what's that dash in
between
you're born and died what are you doing
between where's your dad what does your
dash say this is the basic that's great
and you you have a big dash michael you
know you've you've uh
you've inspired so many people by what
you've done you know and place that you
come from you come from nothing and then
you build this thing
and it's like it's all good but we can
see it it's all grit and gut and heart
and just
you know savages and just do your thing
because that's what you have to do
and we realize it and then we see the
sensitive side of the pigeon
and that thing you know it's like wow
this guy is a beast in the ring but yet
he loves pigeons because it's like a
bird it's like
it's so indicative of life because we
birds we want to fly
but yet we want to be tough too we're
going to do tough things but
the pigeons man that was like wow that's
really really deep so i i really
appreciate that
i learned a lot about you through that
not even talking to you about it but
understood what it was you know
i don't know just you know it has come
from that from like being nowhere right
and then
all of a sudden you're somewhere and
don't know how to really what the [ __ ]
to do when you get
there all right what am i going to do
here right zach i already deserve this
stuff it's again that's that's you
deserve right because if you've been
confident in yourself man this is where
i'm supposed to be this is it no problem
but the thing i like to say also like is
that you know time is our most valuable
asset
uh you know we can never get it back the
time that we
waste the time that we have too fast
whatever yeah
you can never give it back so we have to
be very conscious of our time and that's
why
i appreciate your time with that you're
going to spend with me and my time was
worth coming here because i respect you
that much and i'm so grateful that you
can absolutely
and um life is about our journey
absolutely probably me in our journey
absolutely because our journey will be
over
absolutely and it's just um being um i'm
i'm really happy in my journey and
people standing in my journey
right well i just want to let you know
if you need me for anything but i'm
gonna give you guys my information
appreciate it do you need me anything
whether it be whatever you can call me
i'm always gonna be there
willie for sure willie do you use any
cbd
i don't uh-huh yeah yeah but i got some
of the cream that i'm gonna try
yeah man so i'm gonna try that and uh i
just i've you know the guys look i
i've never drank smoked or done drugs in
my life
yeah just because like what is that
right yeah what is that
i'm always a designated driver for sure
yeah whenever i go with my girlfriends
and friends they always go okay you're
driving okay great no problem ain't my
friend so it's no problem
but when i when i started this athletic
thing when i was very young
i saw first of all i saw people drink
and smoke and they just
abused it and so i was like oh that's
crazy then i said okay i'm an athlete
i want to run as fast as i can be the
best athlete i can if i drink it's not
really going to help me if i smoke it's
not going to help me because it's going
to clog my lawns i won't be fast
so i'm just not gonna do it so i decided
very early not to do it
and i'll tell you a story which will be
in my my documentaries that
when i was probably in a high school
junior high school i had a car
so we would go to practice track
practice and all the guys would be four
guys
i let the guy drive and i sent in the
back the guy lit up a joint or a
cigarette and i roll down the woman and
stick my head out and go what are you
doing i go well i don't want smoke
you just don't want to inhale no they
started laughing i started laughing too
and said oh my gosh your country you're
square
and i go you're right so i left it
myself because it was it was funny but
it was okay and i said
guys it's okay it's just that i think
from me from a mental standpoint
i think it's not going to help me be the
person that i want to be from an ethnic
standpoint i have a 16 year old son that
just totally don't believe in none of
that
20 year old that's great i love it right
yeah that's so
interesting yeah exactly yeah i mean but
you know but the thing about is that
i never uh talk bad about anybody
does it i i encourage whatever i mean
everything in moderation is okay
everything is in moderation is okay it
makes yeah a lot of my friends drink a
lot of my spring
smoke whatever i just okay cool i have
it in my house
yeah yeah the great thing about cbd
though i know you
i've been researching it did you have
any concussions when you played i
probably had
several but back then it's smelling
sauce and go back to the game
can you see one finger yeah okay go back
you guys what are your
do you have any benefits through the
leave
now no yeah you don't right once you
once you retire i think you get two
years and then
all your benefits are basically over i
mean we when i say benefits
your health benefits are mainly right
right because guys have to pay for
insurance and it's so expensive
god but uh i mean something should be
done about it and we're trying to do
something about it but you know it's a
long journey because
it's such a system and i think you know
because i do
uh work with the insurance company we
can do it probably it's going to cost us
15 to 20 million dollars which would
probably be a million dollar per team
for a year
to get all there's probably 20 that's
probably 20 000
guys 15 20 000 guys that are x and fl
players
that need insurance yeah so i'm working
on a system to try to do that but it's
it's
such a machine to talk to you about that
not terrible but they're they're huge
guys you need to have lifetime health
insurance well and the thing about it
mike is this the young guys they don't
really care because they're in it
they're doing they're getting nothing
done they don't realize they're gonna be
where we are
yeah in 10 10 12 years a guy 52 when i
was 20. that was the old [ __ ]
oh god that was right i know
what the [ __ ] do you know about me my
mom and dad was over in their 30s and i
was like
at 15 16 i was like man you guys are old
yeah think about it man
50 years old was like ancient yeah well
you know the nba guys have lifetime
health insurance well i know they do
believe me i know congress has lifetime
insurance
dude and they get a lot of payments we
got to get it i mean
we have to it's a 14 billion dollar
energy yeah this year last year they
made 14 billion dollars in two years ago
and growing that's right so i mean i
think out of that 14 billion which we
help
uh create i think we should be eligible
to be able to at least have uh health
insurance absolutely
because our pension is really not that
great either think about it i played 12
seasons in the national football league
if i retire and get my pension at 55 i
make 3 400
a month 3400 a month in california gets
you back
i mean make it your food and make it pay
for your utilities it won't pay for rain
will take anything she's still homeless
oh exactly not going to happen so
exactly so
right so the poverty level so it's like
you know so but if you wait to 65
i'll get eight over eight thousand
dollars but this is the key here guys
most of the guys in the national
football league they die around 54 to 55
years of age
so they're not expecting you to reach 65
to get the higher amount
that's why they do it yeah it's all i
mean it's all a plan they understand
that if you wait then you're you're not
probably not going to get there very few
guys are going to get there
so i'm going to try to beat them and
make sure i get there
yeah so that's why i stay in shape and
you know do my thing and everything else
so
oh yeah plus i do other things but i was
i was very fortunate when i first signed
with the chicago bears
instead of taking all my money i put it
into an annuity so
i have an annuity that pays me for the
rest of my life anyway from the bears
which was good
and so i i decided not to take all my
signing bonus and i put it into an
annuity which was great and uh
so it worked out really good for me and
now i do that now with my insurance i do
premium finance insurance so
i give guys insurance now there's no
premiums and they get a residual income
for the rest of the lifestyle in 15
years which is good because in 15 years
you know some guys would be 50 60 70 and
they won't worry about it you get six
figures which is cool
premium finance insurance is not for
just your family because life insurance
is for your family it's not for you
it's for when you die yeah see premium
finance gives you money while you're
living
listen i must have health insurance
right because i just had an operation
and it cost like 300 and something
thousands yeah you've got to have f
it's not been like three hundred three
thousand three hundred thousand dollars
i used to pay out of my pocket or behold
you got to come
listen oh my gosh yeah i had no idea
[ __ ] surgery
cost a couple hundred thousand oh yeah
easy what the [ __ ] you got fifty
thousand just by going in the er
listen i will never have that because
there's always plenty and sure you know
oh yeah they ain't sure yeah i started
coming out of my pocket so what
you know and stop going to the doctor
that's exactly what i'm saying
i'm not going to die for me yeah
the check out is that cold yeah yeah oh
man i know
oh yeah it's not very crazy and if you
if you're feeling bad you go to the
emergency room you're looking at
you know it could be several thousand
dollars that's why people don't see
doctors we have insurance through tyson
ranch as well so really we should talk
to you about that okay great yeah
absolutely yeah yeah for sure that's
what i do
i didn't realize the reason i saw my
opponent i saw my check
i mean the receipt that i had to get
paid
for my operation it's 380 000. 880
000. yeah i'm thinking like 38 000 yeah
380
000 for an operation yeah man yeah they
get you
they get it they charge you for
everything they'll charge you whatever
they want they charge for everything man
i'm telling you it's amazing
if you look at the breakdown that's all
new
on you uh a scaffold that's all you
gotta pay for everything it's crazy
somebody had a cup of water to drink
what do you do if you don't have no
money you're not fortunate to do this
stuff you're [ __ ]
dude you gotta fight man you gotta scrap
you gotta do what you can do man
it's it's tough
it is tough it's tough out there so
that's why i you know
i i go back to the avid man we have to
that's it one nation
absolutely insanity then it becomes real
yeah it comes very very
you because you know about you've
experienced it these are my parents
actually absolutely
yeah it's [ __ ] i know it's a terrible
system i don't know what
what do you do you have any thoughts on
well i i i think it's going to be
universal health even yeah i mean like
some other nation
like in london other places you don't
pay for health insurance just go to
doctor
it's paid for by the government but yeah
our government sweden and all those
countries exactly
absolutely but our government when you
look at it education is paid for and
yeah
education they killed me oh yeah i'll
meet you i mean
yeah they think that i'm still fighting
these things yeah oh yeah i paid 20 i
think i'm still fighting
government think i'm still fighting i'm
sorry thank you
15 20 million apart yeah still
yeah it's crazy i mean think about it
guys wait till tyson ridge blows up 15
years 15 years ago when my daughter was
in high school i was paying 24 000
a year for high school just for one
daughter i had two daughters i mean two
a daughter in the sun
and i was paying you know around that
for my son then when she went to college
of course she got a scholarship which
was great because your academic
scholarship which is amazing
and but right now colleges are probably
what 50 or 60 thousand dollars
a year yeah think about that four years
that's 240 thousand dollars yes
all those trips i'm like like the trip
i'm making right now to go to um
cairo whatever that with 400 thousand
whatever that goes to the education oh
yeah
absolutely i'm not getting no funds
it's gone i don't get nothing no play
man i don't get no weed i don't get no
fun
i gotta get nothing out of that money no
no nothing and it's not funny know
what's real i don't know if you have
experience when you have money in your
a substantial amount of money in your
[ __ ] account and it starts to
win doing don't know exactly oh yeah
oh yeah
exactly yeah you know what i mean
you write that last check oh yeah no
it's it's a real thing but still you
gotta pay some bills exactly
somebody got paid to live when you when
you grow up it's it becomes real yeah
yeah
yeah
that's why i tell my kids to stay
younger as long as you can man don't
worry about it
for the future i always prefer my kids
prepare for the future absolutely you
don't realize how
good you have it you don't realize your
parents are taking people you don't
realize
at all how good you have it living at
home not at all
it's crazy it's crazy amazing on to
something more positive mike you're
going to cairo brother tomorrow yes i'm
going to see the pyramid
holy [ __ ] dude are you going to go in
there i saw around four or five of those
um the natural wonders i think i got
three three more to go see
good that's awesome pyramids the
pyramids i got ghosts
english sphinx i gotta go to england
england and see stonehenge
okay and a big band big band and then
you'll see okay yeah okay
right i don't think that's one of the
wonders of the world it's not okay
yeah yeah man willie you ever been there
i've not been to egypt
i've been to africa but i've been in
egypt i went to algeria it was good but
it just looked so scary
oh yeah i had a seven-star hotel in the
middle if it's like
a bomb this all the building he opened
the window he saw abandoned buildings oh
yeah blew up
that's crazy in it i when i was in
africa i saw a mansion that's probably
worth eight to ten million dollars and
then a hut
right next to it that's crazy like made
with the little
the the the tin roof and like just
woods and like a little video and then
another
big house another match another five
million dollar house it's
it's crazy and scary very scary
if michael said scary you know it's
scary people don't realize how good they
have it in america
best country in the world best country
tomorrow i've been all the countries
i've been all around the world to his
best country listen you talk about
racism everybody has racism but listen
imagine a country just because i'm big
and strong i can violate you
and you can't go to the police yeah
that's right now
and then other countries right now in
the world somebody could violate you you
can't go to the police
you go to the police the police will
take you right to them
take you back to him yeah yeah it's
barbaric
man yeah there are some things happening
around the world that's crazy and
us is the best country by far even
though you know we're going through
crazy
trauma things right now it doesn't
really matter it'll it'll be okay it'll
it'll adjust itself you know it's just
part of look at that here's
a violation you can say it's him right
there he has to answer to it
you can violate in these other countries
to the rest of your life you're looking
at this guy
right nothing could happen nothing
happens yeah so we have rights here
which is great
yeah it's scary yeah scary scary thing
[ __ ] dude willie so what do you do these
days man
so you got this documentary got the
document i'm doing that's crazy it's
gonna take me a couple of years to shoot
it
i'm doing financial planning through
life insurance annuities and you know
doing some stocks and bonds and i have a
bonding company
in vegas we do surety bonds for
companies when they're building
buildings to guarantee it
uh and i work out a lot you know i i
go to track ucla the gym i go to gym it
goes gym work out i still compete
in masters i have the master's world
record for my age group
all the way down i have i broken 13
world records in a span of 35 years
hell yeah willie yeah so i i love what i
do i love running and love doing all
those type of things and i i love my
kids i have two kids my son's an artist
mikey mike my kid's 27 and my son's 27
my daughter's 31 my daughter just got
married last year
my son did a pain interview and he sold
it like right away it's amazing yeah
it's amazing he just he just did a big
one a spike lead which i'm going to show
you
it's um it's uh eight feet by eight feet
it's amazing it's huge
huge so i mean he wanted to do something
else of you see on instagram
yeah i mean he's on instagram it's gabe
galt gabe yeah so if you look at it
and i'm gonna show it to you mike which
is it's amazing
the internet yeah it's not good hitting
that here so i'm gonna get
on my here i text it to somebody let me
show him the picture that he did
of spike and my daughter's in real
estate my daughter got married last year
to an amazing guy who i really like
and she's in real estate in beverly
hills so let's look at that that's a
picture you did to spike
oh wow show him him because it's a [ __ ]
how big he is yeah look at that you can
see how big he is
that's dope as hell yeah that's off the
hook
yeah he's 16 the one he did of mike yeah
i got to see that find that one
yeah was it is it a fighting shot it's
no it was a shot with mike just here
with his boxing glove there
i'll show i'll find it so we did one of
the dude the big lebowski
yeah i did with dick lebowski it might
be in this jeff bridges yeah
that's that's [ __ ] right there that's my
[ __ ] yeah
big lebowski yeah so but he's he's
really great really
the first thing to do about painting
what's the first stroke
what are you doing how do you do we
gotta get gabe on the pod absolutely no
he will never do that what's the first
thing you think of the first stroke what
am i doing the first stroke is what
right the first stroke is you get this
imagination okay you you imagine what
you want
you can't stand it i know i know i i
look i have a little bit of authentic
artist artistic drawing abilities but
nothing like him
so first of all you come up with the
image and then you got to draw the image
and then you paint the image or you
paint the image and you draw the image
so it's just it's i love his work
thank you he's really it's really cool
he's done a lot of good stuff
an artist is different than anybody they
have a [ __ ] oh yeah
insight they think differently yeah they
have to because how do you do that how
do you put
you put something in the mirror and they
got put in your mind yeah
exactly it's uh checked it you project
it right absolutely
yeah you're right and what like
materials you use that's interesting
yeah exactly because he uses
you know of course acrylic paint and
spray paint and you know
all medium mixed mediums so he does a
little bit of everything yeah which is
cool
that's awesome yeah so one of the other
things guys we'll talk about body yeah
spike saw it loved it he loved it you
know it's really cool he really loved it
so
uh it's eight minutes he's huge yeah
he's here he's in the team he lives here
he lives in the city well he lives in
sherman oaks which is near me
that's where i live yeah i live in cena
yeah so but his gallery's at my house so
he comes in
and paint locks so i see him a lot
that's just hanging on um
sherman oaks in like the 80s and stuff
he's always have nice girls oh yeah oh
yeah
would you go any clubs in sherman oaks
no nevertheless it's called
the girls right yeah i don't think
there's many clubs exactly
go to clubs club yeah yeah that's cool
one of the things guys
i want to tell you about the winter
olympics and uh
i i was in the 1988
at uh in uh calgary i was there with the
jamaicans i remember
the movie jamaica
you want some ganja come on
i didn't try it but those guys came to
cap to calgary
it was great it was amazing it was
beautiful it was great oh yeah yeah
so it was great they came with no winter
clothes so we started giving them
like winter stuff to race in and and
wear and
their bobsled was just terrible so they
had to get a new bobsled and of course
they weren't very good but it was just
the
the image and the excitement of them
being there and of course they made a
movie
about it and their guys were really cool
those guys were great that's so cool
that was great and of all the guys you
competed with and played when all the
athletes right from from the olympics
from football
who do you keep in touch with the most
people i i stay in touch with my
football guys
you know like otis and and richard dan
and jim mcmahon
i still jim is big
marcus allen's from my best friend stay
in touch with him um tim brown
jerry rice eric dickerson all those guys
are my buddies you know i hang out with
those guys dr jay i see him a lot and
hang out with him
dr j is so cool man this is a cool guy
dr j is amazing
and uh i mean i hang out with a lot of
these guys man they're they're really
amazing guys and i see them all the time
on the golf course because we have a
golf
tournament a lot of the celebrity golf
tournaments so i see them a lot there
which is good i mean because i
got a chance to go around the country
they pay for everything and you play
golf and you get a chance to play golf
with your buddies
it's just a good deal great that's great
hell yeah dude absolutely
yeah enough of my life i hit the ball
listen what happened one day
one day mike on the link isn't it
but the thing about the thing about golf
mike is this everybody started there
everybody started the same place yeah no
matter what everybody started couldn't
hit the ball no by the way you was this
big
it's hard to hear it's this big hard to
hit but it's a great
sport because it's a great business
sport because you have the attention
someone for three or four hours that you
can make deals you can learn a lot about
someone
if they cheat if they you know whatever
i just walk there they're playing i'm
walking and talking
and you can pop deals and you can put
them but you can put to them which is
good
so especially right especially in the
celebrity golf tournament because you
play scramble it doesn't really matter
you got five guys
don't matter right exactly so it's
really good but i play a lot of golf i
love golf
that's awesome what's your handicap i'm
probably about a 10 to 12 depending on
how much i play goodbye you need to pass
that many
people cheating girl oh yeah hell you
tell a lot about you
no you really oh yeah that freaked me
out why are they cheating
how the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are they
cheating for yeah
i just said i got it in two i got it in
four actually yeah
yeah yeah these are grown men
i know it's crazy that's a trip it's a
trip because they want their handicap to
be
you know lower yeah instead of working
they want to just say oh don't worry
yeah all right that's what that's a give
me and the punch from here to the wall
that's a give me
no that's not gonna get me right that's
not a giving no that's like
a two point four foot putt that's a two
putter yeah maybe
it's funny but it's a great sport though
awesome
did you miss all those times you had you
said wait wait more time
of course i could do it again of course
well you you also i think mike
you know you missed the camaraderie with
the guys and the people and the fans
you missed that i mean especially in a
team sport like
football like track is an individual
sport and like box is an individual
sport but
you have that camaraderie with a team
and you're there you're training in
training camp or
and then when you get for the fight
you're all together it's all for one
thing so you go out and win do your best
but i miss i miss that i miss a
camaraderie with the guys on the bus
trips and going in town and going to
movies yeah
going to different cities and coming out
and playing the game and
and have that that genuine
like on the next guy your guy you're
playing with and that brother here that
brothership
and to understand that we're all
fighting for one thing that's a win and
win a super bowl and we were able to do
that that one year and it was
so valuable powerful oh yeah so so
powerful
well i thought it was for boxers and
amateurs we all loved it we rooted for
you before somebody else
but once it became professional it came
about money oh yeah boom
oh yeah it's like there it's like
different you mean you have your guys i
mean
like someone is a different uh division
and it's okay it's like okay cool you
never but if someone in your division is
like okay
you gotta cause you got mad fighting one
day he's like forget that man cause i
don't wanna feel nothing about you i
just wanna go
yeah knock you out yeah that was the
thing so yeah oh yeah i'm still there
for sure yeah
it's crazy that's crazy that's sports
man sports is i
look if i was a coach somewhere or
parents i would require my kids to to
do sports sports teach you so much about
life i mean
bill's character man it builds character
it builds you know camaraderie it
teaches you how to work with a team
i mean to be able to be on the team and
to be able to work together
is what life is all about you know what
you feel overcome your fears of being
not good enough or you know even if
you're not as good as that guy you can
work toward
that i mean sports gives you an
opportunity to work to be the best that
you can be
i mean look i'll never be a boxer like
you the boxer that you were
but i could work to be the best of my
ability and that's what sports is all
about it's about
trying to do your best absolutely about
yourself absolutely
yeah you know because there's guys out
there that talks and you know what i
mean
and i'm listening i'm that and this and
i'm listening i'm the best
and they don't have nothing and there's
guys that have everything they don't
think much of this
absolutely they don't think
it's very interesting it's interesting
different guys are like that right
you're right because of the mind and
mind is crazy mine can play tricks on
you oh
you mentioned i don't meditate i just
i think clearly i don't meditate i just
think clearly yeah never
i've never you know i i look this is
what i do
in any situation i don't rush to judge
anything
i take a beat you know i think about how
it's going to affect me how's it affect
my kids my family the person around me
and me in the future and then i make a
decision so i try to never rush and make
any decisions so when you think like
that
because we get you know sometimes we get
in a situation where
we're like upset you've got to make a
decision but go
okay let me take a beat one two three
let me think about what's
what i'm doing and then you do it then
you react so if you do that
then you make much better decisions
because it's all about making a decision
we make a decision to either go to the
left or go to the right
and if you're in a situation where
you're upset
and the left is making you upset you
don't go there as opposed to if you sit
and think
and go wait a minute that's danger over
there let me just go this way then you
will make that decision
and that's what i try to teach my kids
and people i talk to i go look when
you're in a
crowded situation or in a a situation
where you're angry
don't make a decision think about it
first think about how it's gonna affect
you
how's it affect your family your
surrounding the person you're affecting
and you in the future and then you make
a decision then you'll make a much
better decision
and that's why i try to that's what i
try to do i try to do that every day of
my life
and it's just a part of who i am you
know so you've programmed yourself
program myself to do that yeah
program myself to do that so many people
you know in this day and age they don't
have any like
clue about how to do that though they
don't because they've never done it
right never heard it
because they were beaten into this
mission oh yeah yeah i couldn't know
what to do i had to be beaten in
submission right my main objective was
destroying myself
right not even conscious of it not in
the consciousness of it because that's
just the way you
because you didn't know anything else
that's what you knew that's where you
came from
um i was dying to live yeah that's why i
was dying today right yeah yeah
i was very fortunate mike that you know
when i look at my sister i had a great
mother and a father
i still have a great father my mother
passed away a couple years ago but i had
a great mother and father who was always
there for me
they let me make decisions early in my
life like to go to college i go look
we're not going to tell you where to go
to college
you go where you think you should go and
then if you don't like it then you blame
yourself you can't blame me
which i thought was very smart for me
for me and so
they were always there they're still
always there they taught me right from
wrong my mother taught me how to cook
i can cook anything in the kitchen so
that's awesome so i don't really need
anything
i can do everything myself so my dad
taught me my dad has a sixth grade
education
he knows how to tear an engine out of a
car and put it back together
he knows all general plumbing
electrician carpentry he did all that so
he taught me all that stuff so
a little stuff around my house i can do
all i can do electrician i can do little
plumbing i can do
you know carpentry i can do all that
stuff so because my dick
of course a little i don't mess with my
cat cause cars these days are crazy
yeah yeah but everything else i can do i
mean when stuff break around the house
because when you got a house mic you
know
there's always something to do every day
so i can do those little general things
you know because i'll call a guy
maintenance well i can be there in two
weeks where i need you now so i'll just
go and do it
exactly i need to so i go and do it so i
was very fortunate to have those times i
went from going in and finding youtube
and say how do you fix the leak how do
you fit
this plumbing yeah why not oh yeah yeah
and she's like look idiot yeah that's
how you do it
so i just don't need that i'm just going
to do it now yeah it's cool so yeah it's
really cool
now it's good to learn it's interesting
uh you know i'm only 31 but right
i've owned my home for i don't know four
years now it's interesting i'm like
becoming an adult
life has changed oh know before it was
always the man had to work and the woman
had to stay home
now it's about a family network we have
to work together all right
work together halfway right yeah you got
to work together it's crazy
because that didn't work the mother's
staying at home and the father just
working that didn't work they didn't
know no it's not
fulfilled exactly yeah yeah and it's a
different day it's it's crazy
especially in california man it's great
we have to be in each other's presence
as much as possible yeah
yeah you're right you know communicating
communication communication the key
that's another thing absolutely
ask what you want you got to ask them
what you want you got to tell them what
you want tell them what you're going to
do
so we're all on the same page yeah
that's what everything is about being on
the same page
absolutely absolutely willie thanks for
coming yeah
it's my pleasure this is great i thank
you i appreciate it i appreciate the
opportunity your grandkids
not yet my daughter said a couple more
years so
yeah so i'm looking forward to that at
some point that'll be great
for you you'll be a [ __ ] badass my
kids man oh yeah for sure
i ran my kids to death i just run them
all the time yeah they go dad that's
enough let's know let's keep running
yeah you're tired hey man that's a great
thing to instill in your kid oh yeah for
sure you know
exercise and fitness and taking care of
your body right
but mike i'm going to get my son to do
another painting but i want to give it
to you
so what i want to do is i want i want
you to find the very best picture of you
that you want
something that you want i want this pain
in me cool and that's what we're going
to do okay
i'll do it you tell us what size you
want you won't make it that side i'll
probably get a family painting
okay whatever you want man okay thank
you so much my pleasure brother
thanks welcome man appreciate it thank
you thanks bro i appreciate it
i'm with a quick selfie michael here
with us
i was born in 1960. let me just wrap
this up age my brother oh yeah
great episode mike thank you very much
evan
excellent episode everybody thanks for
listening remember to subscribe on
youtube tell your friends tell your
family we love you guys
until next time we're out of here out of
here
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you